hacia una geografía funcional,
que es como en realidad usamos al mundo,
de naciones y fronteras a infraestructuras y cadenas de suministros.
Nuestro sistema global está evolucionando
de los imperios verticales integrados del siglo XIX
a través de las naciones horizontales interdependientes del siglo XX.
hacia la civilización de red global del siglo XXI.
La conectividad, no la soberanía,
se ha convertido en el principio rector de la especie humana.
(Aplausos)
Nos estamos convirtiendo en esta civilización de red global
porque literalmente la estamos construyendo.
Todo el presupuesto militar en defensa del mundo junto
suma apenas dos billones de USD al año.
Mientras que el gasto global en infraestrutura
se proyecta que ascienda a 9 billones de USD por año
en la siguiente década.
Y, bueno, debería.
Hemos sobrevivido con la infraestructura
pensada para una población global de 3 mil millones.
mientras que nuestra población ha pasado de 7 mil a 8 mil
y finalmente 9 mil millones y más.
Como regla, debemos gastar un billón de USD
en las necesidades de infraestructura básicas por cada mil millones de personas.
No es sorprendente que Asia esté a la cabeza.
En el 2015 China anunció la creación
del banco asiático de inversión en infraestructura,
que junto con una red de otras organizaciones
pretende construir una red de rutas de la seda y el acero,
desde Shangai a Lisboa.
Y conforme esta ingeniería topográfica se desarrolla,
gastaremos más en infraestructura en los siguientes 40 años,
construiremos más infraestructura en los siguientes 40 años,
que lo que hemos hecho en los últimos 4 000 años.
Hagamos una pausa y pensemos.
Gastar mucho más en construir los cimientos de la sociedad global
en lugar de las herramientas para destruirla
puede tener profundas consecuencias.
La conectividad es cómo optimizamos la distribución
de personas y recursos alrededor del mundo.
Es sobre cómo la humanidad se vuelve más que solo la suma de sus partes.
Creo que eso es lo que está pasando.
La conectividad tiene una gran tendencia gemela en el siglo XXI:
la urbanización planetaria.
Las ciudades son la infraestructura que mejor nos define.
Para el 2030 más de dos tercios de la población mundial
vivirá en ciudades.
Y no serán simples puntos en el mapa,
sino un vasto archipiélago que abarque cientos de km.
Aquí estamos en Vancouver,
al principio del corredor Cascadia que se alarga
hacia el sur a través de la frontera hasta Seattle.
La planta de energía tecnológica de Silicon Valley
comienza al norte de San Francisco baja por San José
y atraviesa la bahía hacia Oakland.
La expansión de los Ángeles ahora pasa por San Diego
a través de la frontera mexicana a Tijuana.
San Diego y Tijuana ahora comparten un aeropuerto
del que pueden salir a cualquiera de los dos países.
Una red de trenes de alta velocidad conectará toda la costa del pacífico.
Las megalópolis más al norte comienzan en Boston, a través de N.Y.
y Filadelfia hacia Washington.
Hay más de 50 millones de personas
y también hay planes para una red de trenes de alta velocidad.
Pero es en Asia donde realmente vemos que las ciudades se unen.
Esta linea continua de luz desde Tokio por Nagoya a Osaka
tiene más de 80 millones de personas
y la mayor parte de la economía japonesa.
El la megalópolis más grande del mundo.
Por ahora.
Pero en China, las megalópolis se están juntando
con poblaciones que alcanzan los 100 millones de personas.
El Bohai Rim alrededor de Beijing,
el delta del rio Yangtze alrededor de Shangai
y el delta del rio Pearl
que va del norte de Hong Kong a Guangzhou.
Y en medio,
el grupo de megaciudades de Chongqing-Chengdu
cuya huella geográfica es casi del mismo tamaño
que toda Austria.
Y cada grupo de estas megaciudades
tiene un PIB de cerca de 2 billones de USD,
casi lo mismo que toda la India hoy en día.
Imaginen si las instituciones diplomáticas globales, como el G20,
basaran su afiliación en el tamaño de la economía
más que en la representación nacional,
Algunas megaciudades chinas tendrían un asiento a la mesa
mientras que países enteros como Argentina o Indonesia estarían excluidos.
En la india, cuya población pronto sobrepasará a la China
también hay varios grupos de megaciudades,
como la región de la capital Delhi
y Mumbai.
En el medio oriente,
el Gran Tehran está absorbiendo a un tercio de la población de Irán.
Más de 80 millones de egipcios
viven en el corredor entre El Cairo y Alexandría.
Y en el golfo se está formando un collar de ciudades estado,
de Bahrain y Qatar,
a través de los Emiratos Árabes hasta Muscat en Omán.
Y también está Lagos,
la ciudad africana más grande y el centro comercial de Nigeria,
que tiene planes de una red de trenes
que unirá el vasto corredor atlántico,
desde Benin, Togo y Ghana,
hasta Abidjan, la capital de Costa de Marfil.
Pero estos países serán los suburbios de Lagos.
En el mundo de las megaciudades,
los países serán suburbios de la ciudades.
Para el 2030, tendremos 50 grupos de megaciudades en el mundo.
Así que, ¿qué mapa les dice más?
¿Nuestros mapas tradicionales de 200 países discretos
que tenemos en nuestras paredes
o este mapa de 50 grupos de megaciudades?
Y aún así está incompleto
porque no se puede entender la individualidad de una megaciudad
sin entender sus conexiones con otras.
La gente va a las ciudades para estar conectada,
y la conectividad es el porqué estas ciudades prosperan.
Cualquiera de ellas, ya sea Sao Paulo, Estambul o Moscú,
tiene un PIB cercano o que excede un tercio o la mitad
de sus PIB nacionales.
Pero igualmente importante,
no se puede calcular su valor individual
sin entender el papel de los movimientos de la gente
de las finanzas, de la tecnología
que les permite prosperar.
Tomen la provincia Gauteng de Sudáfrica,
que alberga a Johannesburgo y a la capital Pretoria,
representa un tercio del PIB de Sudáfrica.
Pero igualmente importante, es hogar de las oficinas
de casi todas las corporaciones multinacionales
que invierten directamente en Sudáfrica
y en el continente Africano entero.
Las ciudades quieren ser parte de la cadena de valor global.
Quieren ser parte de la división global del trabajo.
Así es como piensan las ciudades.
Nunca he conocido a un alcalde que me diga:
"quiero aíslen mi ciudad".
Saben que sus ciudades pertenecen tanto
a la red global como a sus propios países.
A mucha gente la urbanización le causa mucho desaliento.
Piensan que arruinan el planeta.
Pero justo ahora,
hay más de 200 interciudades aprendiendo a prosperar juntas.
Son tantas como el número de organizaciones intergubernamentales
que tenemos.
Y todas las redes de interciudades están dedicadas a un propósito,
la prioridad número uno de la humanidad en el siglo XXI:
urbanización sostenible.
¿Se está logrando?
Veamos el cambio climático.
Sabemos que reunión tras reunión en N.Y. y París
no van a reducir la emisión de gases de efecto invernadero.
Pero podemos ver que la transferencia de tecnología
conocimientos y políticas entre las ciudades
es lo que en realidad reduce el uso del carbón en nuestras economías.
Las ciudades están aprendiendo unas de otras.
Cómo crear edificios cero emisiones,
cómo desarrollar sistemas de autos eléctricos compartidos.
En las ciudades chinas más grandes
están imponiendo cuotas al número de autos en las calles.
En muchas ciudades occidentales
las personas jóvenes ya ni siquiera quieren conducir.
Las ciudades han sido parte del problema,
ahora son parte de la solución.
La desigualdad es otro gran reto para lograr la urbanización sustentable.
Cuando recorro megaciudades de principio a fin,
puede llevar horas y días,
veo la tragedia de la extrema desigualdad
dentro de la misma geografía.
Y sin embargo, nuestros mercados globales y activos financieros
nunca han sido tan grandes,
casi cerca de 300 billones de USD.
Es casi cuatro veces el PIB del mundo.
Hemos contraído enormes dudas desde la crisis financiera
pero ¿hemos invertido en el crecimiento igualitario?
No, todavía no.
Solo cuando construyamos suficientes viviendas asequibles,
cuando invirtamos en redes de transporte robustas
que permitan a la gente conectarse tanto física como digitalmente
será cuando nuestras ciudades y sociedades divididas
se sentirán una otra vez.
(Aplausos)
Es por esto que la infraestructura se incluyó
en las metas de desarrollo sostenible de la ONU,
porque permite todo los demás.
Nuestros líderes políticos y económicos
están aprendiendo que la conectividad no es caridad,
es oportunidad.
Por eso nuestra comunidad financiera debe entender
que la conectividad es el activo más importante del siglo XXI.
Hoy en día las ciudades pueden hacer al mundo más susentable
pueden hacer al mundo más justo,
también creo que la conectividad entre las ciudades
puede traer paz al mundo.
Si vemos las regiones que tienen una relación tensa en sus fronteras,
vemos más comercio, más inversión
y más estabilidad.
Todos sabemos la historia de Europa tras la segunda guerra mundial,
la integración industrial detonó un proceso
que dio origen a la pacífica Unión Europea.
Y pueden ver que Rusia, por cierto,
es el menos conectado de los mayores poderes del sistema internacional.
Y eso tiene que ver mucho con las tensiones de hoy en día.
Los países que tienen menos interés en el sistema
también tienen menos que perder al afectarlo.
En EE. UU., la línea más importante en el mapa
no son las fronteras con México o Canadá
sino la densa red de caminos, trenes, ductos,
tendidos eléctricos e incluso canales de agua
que forman e integran los EE. UU.
EE. UU. no necesita más muros, necesita más conexiones.
(Aplausos)
Pero la promesa real de conectividad está en el mundo poscolonial.
Todas esas regiones donde las fronteras han sido arbitrarias históricamente
y donde generaciones de líderes
han tenido relaciones hostiles entre ellos.
Pero un nuevo grupo de líderes ha llegado al poder
y están acabando con los odios.
Tomemos el sureste de Asia, donde la red de trenes de alta velocidad
planea conectar Bankok con Singapur
y rutas de comercio entre Vietnam y Myanmar.
Esta región de 600 millones de personas coordina sus recursos agrarios
y su producción industrial.
Está evolucionando lo que llamamos Pax Asiana,
paz entre los países del sudeste asiático.
Un fenómeno similar se está gestando en África del este,
donde media docena de naciones
están invirtiendo en trenes y corredores multimodales
para que los países sin salida al mar puedan llevar sus bienes al mercado.
Estos países están coordinando sus utilidades
y sus políticas de inversión.
También están evolucionando hacia una Pax Africana.
Un región a la que le conviene este paradigma
es el medio oriente.
Conforme los estados árabes colapsen trágicamente,
¿qué queda sino las ciudades antiguas,
como el Cairo, Beirut y Baghdad?
De hecho, cerca de 400 millones de personas en el mundo árabe
están completamente urbanizadas.
Como sociedades, como ciudades,
son ricas ya sea ricas en agua o sin agua,
con energéticos o sin ellos.
La única manera de corregir estos desequilibrios
no es mediante más guerras y más fronteras,
sino a través de más conectividad de ductos y canales de agua.
Tristemente este no es todavía el mapa de Oriente Medio.
Pero debe serlo,
una Pax Árabe conectada,
integrada internamente
y conectada productivamente con sus vecinos: Europa, Asia y África.
Podría parecer que la conectividad lo es lo más urgente
para una de las regiones más turbulentas del mundo.
Pero sabemos históricamente que es la única manera
de llevar estabilidad a largo plazo.
Porque hemos comprobado, región tras región,
que la conectividad es la nueva realidad.
Las ciudades y los países están aprendiendo a sumarse
a un todo más pacífico y próspero.
Pero la verdadera prueba será Asia.
¿Podrá la conectividad superar los patrones de rivalidad
entre los grandes poderes del lejano oriente?
Después de todo, se supone que ahí comenzará la tercera guerra mundial.
Desde el fin de la guerra fría hace un cuarto de siglo,
al menos seis guerras mayores se han predicho para esa región.
Pero ninguna ha estallado.
Tomen a China y Taiwan.
Hacia 1990 era el escenario propicio para la tercera guerra mundial.
Pero desde entonces,
el volumen de comercio e inversión a través del estrecho se ha intensificado
tanto, que el pasado noviembre,
los líderes de ambas partes mantuvieron una reunión histórica
para discutir la eventual reunificación pacífica.
Y aún con la elección de un partido nacionalista en Taiwan
que es pro independentista el año pasado
no se minó la dinámica fundamental.
China y Japón tienen una historia aún de mayor de rivalidad
y han desplegado sus aviones y buques
para mostrar su poderío sobre las islas en disputa.
Pero en años recientes,
Japón ha hecho la mayor inversión extranjera en China.
Los autos japoneses se están vendiendo en números record ahí.
Y adivinen de dónde son el mayor número de inversionistas extranjeros
que viene a Japón.
Adivinaron, de China.
China e India pelearon una guerra grande
y han tenido tres conflictos fronterizos,
pero hoy en día la India es el segundo inversionista
en el banco asiático de inversión en infraestructura.
Están construyendo un corredor comercial del nordeste de la India
por Myanmar y Bangladesh hasta el sur de China.
Su volumen de comercio ha crecido de 20 mil millones hace una década
a 80 mil millones hoy en día.
La potencias nucleares de India y Pakistán han peleado tres guerras
y aún se disputan Kashmir,
pero también están negociando un acuerdo comercial
y buscan completar un ducto
desde Irán, pasando por Pakistán hasta la India.
Hablemos de Irán.
¿No fue solo hace 2 años que la guerra con Irán parecía inevitable?
Entonces, ¿por qué cada potencia está haciendo negocios ahí hoy en día?
Damas y caballeros,
no puedo asegurar que no habrá una tercera guerra mundial.
Pero podemos ver claramente por qué no ha pasado aún.
Aun cuando Asia alberga las milicias de mayor crecimiento del mundo
esos mismos países están invirtiendo miles de millones de USD
en la infraestructura común y en las cadenas de suministros.
Están más interesados en la geografía funcional del otro
que en la geografía política.
Es por eso que los líderes piensan dos veces, se alejan del borde y deciden
enfocarse en los lazos económicos y no en las tensiones territoriales.
A veces parece que el mundo se desmorona,
pero al crear mayor conectividad
es como regresamos al genio a la lampara,
mucho mejor que antes.
Al conectar al mundo
de modo uniforme físicamente y con conectividad digital
avanzamos hacia un mundo
en el que la gente puede superar sus límites geográficos.
Somos las células y los vasos sanguíneos
que pulsan por esas redes globales de conectividad.
Cada día, cientos de millones de personas están en línea
y trabajan para personas a las que nunca conocerán.
Más de mil millones de personas cruzan las fronteras cada año
y se espera que en la siguiente década la cifra sea de 3 mil millones.
No solo construimos conectividad
la habitamos.
Somos la civilización de la red global
y este es nuestro mapa.
Un mapa donde la geografía ya no es destino.
En su lugar, el futuro nos tiene un lema nuevo y esperanzador:
conectividad es destino.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)